at this point you should have your API
key for the New York Times you're ready
to start grabbing some headlines and the
opening paragraphs to articles your code
is going to be going inside the same
load data function as before you'll be
using the jQuery dollar sign dot get
JSON method to make this Ajax request
it's your job to write the code that
makes the Ajax request once the data has
been returned from the Ajax request
you'll need to parse it and then figure
out how to present it on the page the
link in the instructor notes will take
you to the get JSON documentation on the
jQuery website I recommend checking out
this first example to get an idea for
what your code should do let's open up
dev tools and inspect this page so you
can get an idea of what your HTML should
look like opening up the first article
we see that it contains an a tag - a
link for the article and it also
contains a P tag with the text of the
first paragraph inside in the example
we're passing in a URL string of Ajax
slash test JSON this could be any URL
and we also pass in an anonymous
function this anonymous function passed
to get JSON will be run when the
response returns from the server each
article is in a list tag and they all
fall within an unsigned list with the ID
of New York Times articles I recommend
starting off by console logging the data
that gets returned from this JSON
request you'll need to break it apart
before you can start building articles
so can you make an AJAX request to the
New York Times API and get some articles
about the city you'll need to fire off
the Ajax request iterate through the
response and then present articles on
the page inside the UL with an ID of New
York Times articles check this box when
you're done